welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and marvel's what if has introduced
us to an mcu multiverse full of
limitless possibilities none of which
tony stark will ever live to see half of
this season's first episodes could not
wait to stop the heart of the man who
just got proof that he has won the only
avenger in the series to meet his maker
in every single one of his appearances
even from the kind of fleshed wound he
used to be able to walk away from with a
quick spray of silly string so how have
we now seen five iron man deaths in the
mcu but zero for croaker's supreme uncle
ben did the watcher just really hate
tony's prima nocta joke well we should
ask the one what if character to die
even more than him christine palmer
whose death was considered an
unchangeable absolute point in time a
new term that this series introduced to
the mcu lexicon and by this logic could
tony stark's death be an absolute point
not just in our universe but in every
reality within the expanding marvel
multiverse does his martyrdom play such
a linchpin role in the next generation
of marvel mythology and or does his
existence just really piss off the wrong
nexus being we know tony stark's death
and avengers end game was necessary and
of course ended the battle of earth it
saved us from thanos and it's now
forcing a younger generation to step it
up and stop handing off your glasses to
just anybody but ever since many of us
have questioned the necessity of tony's
death now yes we're big boys enough to
know that robert downey jr was ready to
move on and endgame did a great job of
setting up and paying off tony sacrifice
play but at the same time the genius
billionaire who discovered freaking time
travel in a man cave with only one
morgan could have found any number of
ways as he sassed to america's ass cut
the wire like better shielding to
withstand cosmic radiation or instead of
snapping all six stones and frying
yourself throw it along with just the
mind stone like ultron did and make
thanos balanced that's all things should
be or my preferred option just use the
space stone to pour behind thanos and
the reality stone to erase his booty
hole and then just walk away and let
nature take its course
[Music]
but then after we learned that all mcu
events were scripted according to a
sacred timeline overseen by he who
remains there is some evidence that kang
the conqueror could have been in cahoots
with other cryptic pajama wearers like
the ancient one or the watcher to
manipulate tony stark via dr strange's
mind games to believe that a sacrifice
play was the only way to victory and in
this season of what if as tony stark's
destiny from cave to super secret boy
band to cool but arguably unnecessary
suicide was codified by the watcher as
quote the age of iron man while every
other multiversal wrinkle seems to
demand a blood sacrifice from the man of
iron in episode 3 he's the first murder
victim in hank pym's anti-avengers
killing spree face planting with an
undignified mouthful of randy's donuts
in episode 5 he gets tackled by zombies
on the golden gate bridge and then is
denied any possible salvation from the
survivor's mind stone reversion plan by
hope van dyne lobbying off his head and
feeding it to one of her giant ants in
episode six one of those vital organs in
the armpit region just couldn't take
killmonger spear longer than 40 seconds
somehow without bleeding a drop and then
episode 8 beats up on him again as the
bonehead who unleashed ultron on the
world just to show him begging for his
life and having his pacifism project
call him a pee brain before offing him
you don't have to do this i made you for
peace it's evolution only a primitive
mind would fail to see the distinction
which is why you have to die
so let's roll those back
start tony
it's hard not to see this as personal
especially when you consider that steve
rogers t'challa thor peter parker scott
lang clint barton natasha romanov steven
strange captain marvel and bruce banner
all avoided on-screen deaths at least
once on this show now i could see the
possibility that he who remains or
another kang variant would seat someone
like tony stark a man who unlocked the
secrets of time travel without another
variant stepping into his universe to
share notes with as a major threat to
kang's time empire if tony stark were
left alive it would only be a matter of
time for him to follow in kang's
footsteps build on his own quantum
navigation tech that he devised an
endgame and eventually hunt kang down
throughout the time stream kang a
scientist born in the 31st century
likely needed tony stark to die a
premature death to leave behind
incomplete quantum research that only
nathaniel richards a millennium later
would be able to dust off and exploit to
his advantage where no other scientists
during that thousand years could now
look folks here in the blue dungeon we
got some hot hot lights that just get
hotter when i'm not really certain
whether something's really an easter egg
so yeah sometimes i can get a bit sweaty
well luckily native deodorant not only
keeps me from permanently funkifying the
whole blue dungeon their deodorant is
aluminum free and paraben free it's made
from familiar and simple ingredients
that you know like coconut oil and shea
butter i have these scents eucalyptus
mint charcoal and earl grey and mulberry
eucalyptus mint is just like fresh it's
like it's like rolling through the
freshest garden patch of the world you
don't actually want to do that because
bugs and thorns and stuff so just use
this but i guess i also really love the
earl grey mulberry it's like waking up
and bathing in a giant teacup but today
i use the charcoal
and like no regrets i feel like a man
which most days i just feel like a widow
boy and i'm loving it it's not too
sticky it dries quickly great for when
you're in a rush and just needing to
slap it on native stays all day even
after exercise or after a full day of
work and they have a ton of different
kinds of scents including limited
edition fall sense inspired by coffee
house scents native also offers a
plastic free version of their deodorant
using more sustainable packaging they
also have amazing body washes and
toothpaste and last year they donated
over two million dollars worth of
product to hope and comfort a non-profit
organization to help deliver health and
confidence to those in need and that is
amazing so be sure to check out native's
new limited edition coffeehouse
collection three deodorants are normally
36 dollars but if you use our link and
code rockstars you'll get them for 24
that's 33 off with code rockstars you
can also get 20 off any body wash or
toothpaste so jump on that and thanks
again a native for sponsoring this
episode but how exactly does the logic
of absolute points even work according
to what if like we didn't even know the
concept of absolute points even existed
as a rule until what if episode four
when the ancient one explained her death
is an absolute point in time absolutely
unchangeable unmovable
without her death you would never have
defeated dormammu and become the
sorcerer supreme you cannot reverse an
absolute point to which we all responded
sure but we know of a universe where
steven strange does all that without
christine palmer having to do anything
more than let strange grope her face a
bit and then safely exit stage right
from the movie she doesn't have to die
so christine palmer's death is only an
absolute point in the universe that
episode of what if took place in not all
realities so moving over to tony stark
his death and end game does follow the
same logic as christine palmer's because
doctor strange also used the time stone
repeatedly fast-forwarding 14 million
605 times to conclude that there was
only one path to victory a path that he
claimed at least via non-verbal hand
signals required tony stark's death so
the way dr strange used the time stone
to exhaust every possible alternative
for christine so too may he have done
for tony stark and found that tony's
inevitable sacrifice play was an
absolute point and from this i think we
conclude that yes tony stark's death was
likely what the mcu's own rules consider
to be an absolute point but beyond that
something even more significant because
unlike christine palmer tony stark's
death seems absolute in every universe
not just one why is kang just snuffing
out the competition maybe but also
something interesting happens when tony
stark dies in a universe seems to clear
the way for villains like episode 3 loki
episode 5 thanos episode 6 killmonger
and episode 8 ultron to rise and for new
hero alignments to form to face them on
a broadening multiversal front so far
we've gotten an avengers co-captain by
steve rogers and carol danvers black
panther spider-man and scott lang's head
shuri pepper potts in the dora melange
and the watcher in dr strange when he
was alive tony stark's gravity pulled
everything around him so strongly that
other characters are really trapped in
his orbit but now without him new
spheres of influence are emerging and
new character combinations are arising
the true secret agenda of what if and
the real life watchers pulling its
strings is to acclimate marvel viewers
to a multiverse that does not have to
revolve around tony tony stark must die
so that other marvel heroes learn to
fight on a multiversal battleground and
without the pressure of a one day tony
stark reincarnation still having to be
the future of the franchise marvel
studios is now more liberated to bring
back the tony stark character in
whatever weird or experimental ways they
want and no longer feel the pressure to
live up to robert downey jr's version of
the character in the meantime for
viewers to learn to let go of the
specific rdj incarnation of that front
man that we've loved three thousand it
will help to watch him kick the bucket
upwards of three thousand times as much
as it may stick support new rockstars by
checking out our merch options at
noxstarsmirch.com follow me on instagram
and twitter eavoss follow and subscribe
to new rockstars thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you